1 2 1 pour l'enfance en un mois 2 0 pour
la france 2 1 pour la france 3 pour la
france
les supporters ont cru à la victoire de
la france pour son dernier match de
poule face à la suisse ils sont venus en
nombre au complexe sportif pierre de
coubertin de montigny le bretonneux
suivre la rencontre sur écran géant et
encourager les bleus
ils ont eu l'occasion de vibrer dès la
première mi temps avec les tentatives
françaises
une belle première mi temps avec deux
deux poteaux quand même pour les bleus
donc confiance confiance ça va finir par
rentrer ça a bien joué
un peu déçu mais je suis positif et je
pense que me tendant marque au retour
des vestiaires les bleus perdent la main
sur le match
l'impatience règne dans la salle jusqu'à
la rentrée de dimitri payet et sa
reprise de volée à la 77e minute sur la
transversale qui réveille le public
score final 0 à 0 les réactions après la
rencontre sont mitigés entre espoirs et
déceptions déçu déçu parce que très
grand petit travail on sait pas trop il
ya eu deux tirs sur la barre qui nous
réjouit c'est un peu ça il galère contre
la suisse mais après je me demande
qu'est ce qu'on va faire péter le mal
tout ça parce que la suisse ait pas une
équipe non plus trop forte c'est pas mal
du tout surtout en première mi temps pas
mal de rythme un petit peu moins en
deuxième on a un peu plus subi mais
l'essentiel c'est de finir premier de la
poule et du coup c'est réussi avec le
match nul il suffisait d'un match nul
donc l'aventuré continue on sera
derrière derrière les bleus pour le
prochain match et les prochains matches
la france termine première de son groupe
et les supporters pourront continuer à
encourager les bleus dimanche prochain
lors de leur huitième de finale